you mentioned the bible you've been
talking about how it's your favorite
book
and you said i think last night in iowa
some people are surprised that you say
that
i'm wondering what most favored bible uh
verses are
i wouldn't want to get into it because
to me that's very personal you know when
i talk about the bible it's very
personal so i don't want to get into
girls
hey i'm just kidding america you know i
love you now the fourth and fifth
episode of race by wolves have just
dropped on hbo max
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking them down obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
them out yet then i highly recommend
that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns on the full season
and please drop a thumbs up as you know
it helps us out massively
now without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into raised
by
wolves okay so firstly just a quick
correction from last week's video
in it i stated that the necromancers
were created by the atheists
however as many of you correctly pointed
out it was actually the methodic that
created them and the machines were
actually reprogrammed by one of the
characters that we meet in the episode
and there's actually a lot of religious
imagery that hints to this
such as the pose that mother pulls when
going into attack mode
that's very similar to a crucifixion one
there's also of course the adam and eve
of mother and father
and the arc which the humans traveled on
which shares similarities with noah's
on the whole the show is laced with this
iconography
so yeah sorry for being a doo doo head
now episode 4 picks up with mother
searching for paul after becoming lost
in the woods last time
he stumbled across what appeared to be
tally and then fell into one of the many
pits on the planet
and the character almost falls to his
death before he's rescued by mother
i actually think that paul is the person
that the pentagonal prophecy is centered
around
and that was simply being duped into
believing that it's champion
because that's the most obvious choice
as we said in our first breakdown
the phrase raised by wolves comes from
the story of romulus and remus
which was about two brothers that
founded rome if we're correct then both
paul and campion will be metaphors for
this myth
with them founding a new civilization on
the planet
however if we're also right then that
means that one has to kill the other
and personally i can see it being
champion that does this
again these are all just theories but it
does sound like an older version of the
character doing the voice over at the
start of episode 1
so it could be teasing that he makes it
through now the myth right themselves
get a lot of attention these episodes
and i think we definitely need to talk
about them the mithraic were actually a
real world religion
that existed back in roman times and
once more
this ties back into the romulus and
remus metaphor similar to what we see in
the show they worshipped a god known as
sol
and sul of course translates to sun a
symbol which can be seen emblazoned on
their uniform
marcus steps up as their leader
throughout these episodes and we'll
likely deal with the aesthetic of an
atheist
actually being a leader of the methodic
on the other side we'll have champion
who's actually open to being religious
and he will become the leader of the
atheists
so we will have this dichotomy of an
atheist leading the matriarch
and vice versa now the planet is clearly
being teased as having intelligent life
on it
and early on in episode four the
mithraic discover a structure that has
been designed
this looks extremely similar to a
pentagon and again it could be playing
into the prophecy
as we said last time kepler-22b is a
planet that can actually support human
life
and thus it could already have people
living on it
we'll get into that later though and
elsewhere mother returns paul and tells
the children to keep their eyes closed
as she's weaponized
again there's a strange thing going on
here where being blind to the
necromancers
might actually be the key to remaining
immune to their scream attacks
who knows the mithraic might even end up
doing the bird box challenge to beat
mother
but it could also mean absolutely
nothing we discover that mother can also
put people to sleep by speaking to them
and it does seem that all of her power
descends from a voice
so i'm still a bit confused over the
whole eye thing
if she wanted to put them to sleep maybe
she should have just put on episode two
am i right no now this this show is
pretty good as a day anyway
clearly there's descent in the camp and
paul is slowly being won round to the
androids after they saved his life
there's a lot of religious back and
forth with hunter stating that mother
only arrived because they prayed to
seoul
and it's very much divine intervention
versus coincidence
mother bonds with tempest in a room and
this girl very much holds the key to the
future of the planet
as she's the only person pregnant on
kepler that we know about
she's gonna be instrumental in the
survival of the human race
and i think mother is getting close to
her because she secretly wants her on
her side when things go down
they have a lot of boy talk and it's
another shining example of how mother
can express human emotion
such as compassion and love however if
she has these
it also means that she possesses the
worst of humanity
such as hate and fear and i think over
time she'll be revealed as the true
villain of the piece
now she fishes out the tracking device
from tempest and the rest of the
children
before she dumps it down a canyon she is
of course aware that the methoric are on
the planet
and is clearly sending them on a wild
goose chase at the camp sue pleads with
the elders to go after the kids
but they refuse i think it shows how
short-sighted they are
as if they have no children then the
species cannot thrive on the planet
and it's a very selfish view of how to
handle the situation
they would rather crack the stone
structure and marcus slowly begins to
realize more and more
just how useless they are sue doesn't
know one of the founding lullabies of
the religion
and this gives away that she's an
imposter to their leader ambrose
it seems like the ai member of the group
hijacks marcus's motor functions to make
people believe that he may have been
compromised by the necromancer
however we learn that it's ambrose who's
actually behind it
he wants to take marcus out after
learning the truth and knows that
sue is valuable because of her medical
skills marcus enacts a plan to oust him
and he comes to a fiery end that saves
the camp and of course
allows marcus to step into his place
elsewhere we joined father and champion
who are searching for a new food source
after the pips and the cabos were
discovered to be radioactive
they have a real father and son moment
here but ultimately fail
and only come across food which has
cyanide in it
this is of course a lethal poison and it
may be possible that it's actually used
as a weapon
by the group when fighting the mithraic
he and mother come to blows over whether
to treat tempest organically or not
and it's clear they're not on the same
page with father's ego being
crushed after he realizes that mother is
far more useful than he is
in the end he comes to the conclusion
that though he's not as physically adept
as she is
he can teach campion in other ways he
attempts to get the children to kill the
beast
but they all come up with excuses and
ultimately start the process
but leave the animal to suffer longer
throughout the episode
mother ventures to some of the orc
wreckage and using one of the stasis
chambers she enters the simulation
where she finds a preacher i might be
wrong but i think this is the character
that impregnated tempest
and we will be talking about him more in
the breakdown now mother goes off into a
fantasy
pulled from her memories and she sees
from a third person perspective
how cruel she used to be to a surrogate
son however
she also sees the other side of herself
and we realize
just how complicated of a machine that
she is i think the show will ask whether
artificial intelligence will one day be
capable of love
and it's interesting seeing her develop
as a character
tally revisits father one night and
draws him away from the camp
and tempest using the scalpel that
mother created to pull out a tracker
goes and kills the creature she finds
out that the beast was pregnant
and this of course mirrors our own
journey the mithraic view killing is
something in pure
unless one is given permission and this
will of course cause
a lot of issues for the character's
psyche at the start of episode 5 we join
a hooded figure
who fishes out the tracking device and
with them they move across the planet
marcus also begins to hear voices and
who knows
the faith might actually be getting to
him with the rest of his forces they
find a device that can help to combat
mother
and also the member of the craft that
raped several of the women in
hibernation on the ark
he's had a helmet placed on his head
that can crush his skull
and this has been paired with an android
they plan to use him against mother
and the pieces are slowly falling into
place for their counter-attack
slowly the mithraic begin to prop marcus
up as their leader
even giving him ensue extra rations and
they very much
slot into their new identity father
takes the children out hunting
and paul and campion discover one of the
planet's inhabitants in one of the pits
through it they discover fungus that
they can eat and paul and campion
really begin to build their brotherhood
here and it's going to be interesting to
see how their partnership develops
father realizes that he's actually
controlled by mother who pretty much
rules over him
and makes him feel even more inadequate
due to his parenting
she goes searching for more creatures
and comes across another vision of tally
who may or may not be real after
reconnecting with the pod again
we see the war on earth from her
perspective and also
finally meet campion this is the
scientist that reprogrammed her
and entrusted her with the embryos now
in the first set of episodes
we learned that no one on the side of
the atheists was able to reformat the
necromancers
so this must have been someone that did
a benedict arnold
we learned that campion was born into an
affluent family
and then switched sides capturing mother
before forcing her to change in order to
become the species
greatest protector instead of its
greatest weapon
campion brought her a synthetic baby
which he killed
due to believing that it was an atheist
however over time
he does completely change her we see the
moment that champion erases her
memory and he sends her out to kepler
22b in order to take care of the embryos
which of course kickstarted the show
campion had to remain on earth because
he'd be unable to survive the trip
and he erased her memories but it
becomes clear that he did love her
the relationship i felt was definitely
the high point of the season so far
and seeing mother rediscover this it's
kind of heartbreaking
now mother is forced to wake up upon
learning a child that the settlement is
in danger
and she arrives to find tempest at
death's door she states she's sick of
being viewed as a walking incubator
and their relationship begins to strain
even though
mother genuinely cares for her elsewhere
the mithraic tracked the tracking
devices to the skeleton
of a large snake-like creature the
entire location is booby-trapped
and the mysterious figure returns to
take these
though they have more questions than
answers they do find a map of the area
and the strangest possessions
and he's marked out an entire settlement
that the androids and their children are
at
now who exactly is this well due to the
lack of characters that we've seen so
far
i think that it could be champion
campion may have traveled out to the
planet shortly after mother and father
and he could have watched them from afar
as they raised the children
he could be waiting in the shadows to
come out should something go wrong
but again this theory is based purely on
what we know about the show so far
which is very little it could be an
alien and there are comments that it
doesn't move like a human
but at this point who knows now whatever
it is
it's dress very similar to tally and it
is likely that this is the thing that's
been looking after her
it would be difficult for a child to
survive on this planet without
assistance
and thus i think that the dress swear is
very similar to show
that it has been her guardian marcus
confronts the criminal
and questions why he did what he did in
the name of seoul
he realizes that he's a scumbag using
religion as a guide to cover his crime
and he says that saul has stopped
talking to him and it is possible that
the voice marcus has started hearing
is the voice of the deity or something
masquerading is it
this voice could tell marcus to do
something that too may be a crime
i think he's slowly starting to slip to
the other side
which will be what he wrestles with over
the next couple of entries
he begins to hallucinate that he must
kill his wife and starts to see himself
in the same helmet as the criminal
something on the planet is clearly
affecting him and he finds paul's
footprints before the group finally
discover the camp
they watch over it and marcus smiles as
the episode cuts to black
so what's gonna happen next well i think
the campaign to get the children back
will be a slow one
and that the group will likely wait
until nightfall before they make their
move
the children no longer have the tracking
devices in them
so it could be impossible for mother to
find them
however if the matheraic are smart they
might also wait until mother is at a
most vulnerable before they attack
and the group could stalk her for a
while until they see an opening
as we know when she goes into the
simulated reality
she's almost in a sleep-like state and i
think that this would be the perfect
time for them to attack
again these are all theories but i think
they're gonna have a plan
rather than just going in organs blazing
anyway
that's all the episodes and i know that
much didn't happen
but i am really enjoying the show and
you know
it's very intriguing it has a slow pace
to it but there's a lot of atmosphere
here
and the characters are all slowly being
developed with you know what father
he's probably becoming my favorite now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
and theories
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the first three episodes
which will be linked at the end
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to bear with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of september and the set will be shipped
out from then to ever get surprise
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part if you want to support the channel
and get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat this under
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you